this animation is brought to you by the
smart image base
a subscription website where you can
download thousands of medical
images and videos to use in lectures
courses
presentations professional training and
more for more information
click on the link in the description
an inguinal hernia usually shows up as a
bulge
in the lower abdomen also called the
groin
or the scrotum before
birth a male baby's testicles grow
inside his abdomen
and then travel to the scrotum to get to
the scrotum
the testicles must pass through two
openings called the
internal and external
inguinal rings and a passage between
them
called the inguinal canal formed by
abdominal wall muscles
as the testicles enter the scrotum
tissue lining the abdominal wall comes
with them
forming a sac
normally the opening of the sac into the
inguinal canal closes within six months
after birth
sometimes for unknown reasons the
opening of the sack does not close
as a result the open tissue sac may fill
with fluid that normally stays inside
the abdomen
the fluid-filled sac surrounding the
testicle is called a hydrocele
a small piece of the baby's intestine or
some fatty tissue from the abdomen may
also slide into the sac
resulting in an inguinal hernia
usually a doctor will be able to gently
reduce
or push the intestine back into the
abdomen
however the intestine may become trapped
or incarcerated
inside the tissue sac this will appear
as a hard
and tender bulge and is an emergency
after about six hours the intestine
inside an incarcerated hernia
may lose its blood supply and die this
is called a strangulated hernia
and is an emergency that requires
immediate medical attention
and surgery to repair it hydroceles and
inguinal hernias require an operation to
tie off and remove the tissue sac
to prevent future herniation and
possible injury to the small intestine
to begin the surgeon will make a small
incision near the hernia
next the surgeon will carefully separate
the tissue sac
away from the cord structures including
small blood vessels and the vas deferens
that are attached to the testicle the
surgeon will then
open the sac to look for any herniated
contents inside
usually the sac is empty however
if herniated contents are present they
will be moved back into the abdomen
sometimes in children younger than two
years of age
the surgeon will insert an instrument
called a laparoscope through the open
tissue
sac the laparoscope contains a camera
that will allow the surgeon to look at
the internal ring
on the other side and see if there's a
hernia on that side
if the other internal ring is open and
there is a hernia
the surgeon will need to make a similar
repair on that side
after checking the other side for a
hernia the surgeon will tie off the
empty tissue sac
with a suture the remainder of the sac
will be removed
finally the surgeon will close the
incision with dissolvable sutures
skin glue or closure tape dressing
the baby may receive an injection of
anesthesia in the skin near the incision
to help control pain that happens after
the procedure
to find out more about the repair of a
pediatric inguinal hernia
talk to your healthcare provider